well Disney's Bambi is L's victim of the
woke war on culture a screenwriter hir
to remake the classics say the movie's
most famous scene in which Bambi's
mother sadly dies could be scrapped as
it's triggering for modernday parents
and their children she elaborated in
this interview with kider what's
interesting about Bambi to me is it
absolutely is a classic is it's such a
gorgeous film it's a little bit
different Tempo than I think um modern
audiences are used to and I also think
there's a there's there's a treatment of
the not to spoil the plot but there's a
there's a there's a treatment of the mom
dying that I think some kids some
parents these days are more sensitive
about than they were in yes in the past
and I think that's one of the reasons
that they haven't shown it to their
children but our take on it was um did
give a little bit more of a of a scope
to it and I just think that to be able
to bring it to life for kids these days
in a way that maybe they relate to a
little bit more would would be of of
service to the original
how she going to feel when I order
venison for my dinner tonight children
are facing an epidemic of anxiety
apparently maybe because we feel the
need to protect them so ridiculously
much all the time now from Bambi to
discuss this I'm joined by out host
Tommy L the author for the case for ccil
culture Ernest Owens welcome to both of
you from across the pond all right
Ernest you've defended the indefensible
a few times on this program but come on
for goodness sake we're going to try and
airbrush the reality of Bambi's mom
getting slaughtered what's the matter
with
you well there's nothing wrong with me I
think that the reality is that as
Society evolves we should also think
about you know the impact you know we
are in a different type of world now you
know there's a lot of violence on TV
there's a lot of of grotesqueness and I
think that this classic film should be
seen by with a different perspective for
kids I think that the de scene isn't
necessarily the thing that they should
be fixated on I think there's something
to be said about how you you know
children deal with death and and death
scenes compared to adults like you and I
and I think that this is a very smart
move I think it's a move that is
considerate I think that it shows
progress and I think to be honest you
know I think some parents would rather
have that conversation with their
children privacy of their home rather
than having these films you know kind of
traumatize what's next you going to
remake jewels and make sure this shark
doesn't eat anyone case someone's
triggered and can't go swimming it's
nuts uh Tommy this is just nuts isn't
it it's nuts and I would also like to
say I wish they would stop remaking
Disney Classics we talked about this I
think a couple months back this remake
the Snow White they have to make it for
woke audiences does Disney really not
have any other ideas can they not come
up with anything new that they have to
remake all the classics so that's my
first point on it and second of all I
believe in protecting children I just
find it quite interesting that the same
woke liberals that are worried about
this hunting scene in Bambi have no
problem exposing children to gay porn
and lgbtq themes telling them that they
are born in the wrong body encouraging
them to be nonbinary I mean really I'm
waiting for this Bambi remake to have
Bambi as a trans deer or maybe the
mother died from climate change so again
the things that the left and the
Liberals are triggered by always
astounds me I think that there are far
worse things you can expose children to
that the left is exposing children to
than a hunting scene that's actually a
reality of life especially here in the
United States with a lot of hunters love
it or hate it that is a fact of of where
we are in this country and I think in
many places around the world do you know
what Ernest I think you've been
persuaded by that argument I can see
you're nodding away
furiously I I think this is ridiculously
homophobic and transphobic I think for
starter I'm gay and me being here
talking isn't exposing children to
anything but if I was to pull out a gun
as a hunter and shoot a a deer for a
kids to see I think that's going to
cause more harm to a child than just me
just basically existing and living my
life um I think it's ridiculous to make
that conflation between you know gay
porn to a a deer being killed when in
reality no one is actually promoting gay
porn no one from the left is encouraging
that for children and to conflate those
things in that way is intellectually
dishonest and immature and problematic
Hest we literally had Snow White and the
Seven Dwarves redone recently and the
airbrushed all the dwarves out of the
movie right because apparently they want
to be they want to be inclusive the
people they didn't include were the
actual dwarves who then now all out of
work this is where this version you know
what you you know what you could do you
could rather than whining about new
things you can just go and stay stuck in
1939 and watch the Disney animated film
I would love to you can do that I would
love to and and other people can watch
and other people and then I can watch my
Disney film what we have but Earnest
then I can watch my Disney films without
people like you ruining them right I'm
trying to pretend
watch M Pier I hear that pierce I missed
the old Pierce borgan I used to
interview Beyonce and hang out with the
Liberals in Hollywood and be nice but
now I have this new Pierce one that's
Unleashed and guess what there's there's
value in both for some people no have
two things at the same time I'm one
Ernest I'm one of these ostracized
liberals where I used to think I was
liberal and then the woke left came
along and I realized actually by their
yard stick I'm right of a till of the
Hun cuz I think everything they do wreck
Society I really do and when you go back
and remake a Disney classic and you you
presume that kids can't deal with the
death of a deal you're Prov my you've
all gone mad but Piers you're no Piers
you're proving my point things evolve
right and so there's a new version of
you that you think has evolved and this
Creator who's creating the Bambi film
thinks this can evolve and there's could
to be people that say I miss the O
missing the point the old show the CNA
days no I think that's the point we can
we can let two things exist honest just
to be clear I haven't evolved at all I'm
exactly the same as I always was it's
just the people I used to agree with
have broadly gone mad uh Tommy the
problem with this is It's a real
slippery slope I think once you start
going after every classic it's a bit
like every historical figure they're all
flawed there's no American president
history who won't be cancelled by this
yardy there's no founding father that
won't be cancelled there is no film that
won't be there's no hang on Ernest
they're dead hang on Ernest this is a
fictional film film bamby's mother's
dead Ernest wake up Tommy Tommy this is
for Tommy they're dead this is for Tommy
I know they're dead so is Bambi's mom
and she should stay dead every time you
watch a movie Tommy I also think I
also Tommy I think that there are you
know more problematic things to have to
explain to Children besides the death of
animals I think that that is the circle
of life I think we learned that in The
Lion King we learned that from a lot of
Disney Classics but you know in the last
segment you were talking about the L and
the rioting and the shoplifting kids are
exposed to that every single day
certainly in the United States and I
don't hear liberals worried about them
being exposed to that they call that
Justice right but they're worried about
a scene in which Bambi's mom dies I mean
the priorities again to me are so
astounding yeah I completely agree uh
the reach is to me outstanding the reach
the reach you're conflating looters to
people who don't want a Bambi scene like
this is a reach
you should be stressed let's leave it on
a reach uh Ernest always good to catch
up with you Tommy great to see you too
thank you both very much indeed all
right uh my P you were sort of
convulsing the three of you about this
debate but AA at the heart of this
debate lies my basic belief that we are
we're covering our kids in so much
cotton wool they are woefully ill
prepared for the real world and I'll
explain why when we brought in
participation prizes for sports day
right all that means is kids do not
learn what losing involves what not
winning involves you don't get
participation prizes in the real world
you win you lose you lose a job you get
a job whatever there's no reality to
this now all the films are been
sanitized because apparently kids can't
deal with these I'm fine I watched all
these films it didn't turn me into some
corrupted mass murderer or make me flake
out it just it was a film that had that
sad moment and your heart goes like that
when when you watch it what's wrong with
allowing kids to watch the reality well
I don't agree with your first bit
because I you know we we actually do
have participation prizes in life and
that is just you know not being best not
being number one at not all times are
you number one you're just existing game
you don't in the media you don't no one
gives you a prize for becoming eighth
well last maybe I would like one the
British press awards for example nobody
no newspaper gets an award for coming
last but can I say on your second point
there you know we actually already did
soften these fairy tales you know these
all originate from Grim's fairy tales I
like the Grim hang on but you look at
The Little Mermaid and that was H
Christian Anderson and it was a really
gruesome tale you know we already did
soften gr tals but we already did soften
them down so now when we're talk my
daughter look Grace my daughter my
daughter's nearly 12 she writes like
really quite full on gruesome stuff
right and I it's fascina got a very
creative mind very febra mind very you
know all over the place but she writes
really riveting things but it's often
based on Fantastical stuff right this is
what we all grew up with why why we
trying to pretend the real world is some
at Disney is a marketing genius because
they are in the news every week every
month we've remade this show and the
character is a different race or we're
cutting this scene and it's going to
really annoy Piers Morgan and it's going
to be all over his show for weeks and
weeks and weeks and weeks and even
though he hates it Pi Morgan is going to
go to the cinema and he's going to watch
that film and everyone who watches his
show is going to watch that show is
going to know that b coming out again
and it's going to make us tons and tons
of I can't watch B's mother being killed
I'm not going to watch it what Horror
Story look I wasn't a fan of like snow
beige and the southern genderist Widgets
or whatever it turned out to be but but
but but I do think the overwatching
point is make new stories for the love
of God stop remaking them and just
making them you know yellow and green
and you know having some one-legged
Chinese trans person or whatever just
make new story it's interesting to me
that nnest was convinced that I have
evolved to a new place on this stuff
right I haven't I'm exactly the same
person I've always been but the the sort
of the world that I thought the liberal
world was about has changed so
dramatically this woke stuff is
completely mad most of the time I don't
agree I don't think you would have read
your children the Grim's fairy tales yes
of course I would have gone for the nice
soften version of course I would you
would have gone for the nice because you
would you'd like the soft version my
kids if we play sport we played a win
right I've never given them an inch now
the older ones beat me okay good but
they' learned the joy of beating their
dad cuz I didn't let them ever win when
they were kids I'd rather beat them 10 n
and let them win or score a goal I mean
part of the problem with what we were
discussing before this whole knif crime
epidemic is actually we do have this
society that consistently tells people
they're either winners or losers B on
how much money they earn based on
whether or not they have a good car and
there are the same people who end up
consistently on top as winners the same
people who end up consistently on top as
losers and the people who feel like they
are losers because there are no paths
for them to change their lives or to
change anything about themselves end up
basically taking their Revenge either on
themselves or on the rest of society
that is what you have when you have a
society that is structured basically by
telling people you're worth something
and you're not in your world everyone's
a winner even if they're lazy work shy
don't put the shift in they're still win
no my world is a world in which people
are different and cannot be compared by
weird little league tables that tell you
if you have more money then you're a
better person I don't I think money's
got nothing to do with it but it does
you know you live in an incredibly
material soet there are for example
there are brilliant nurses
where money is not and they get paid
nothing we don't value them tell them
what they're doing isn't worth it money
is not a comparative thing in hospital
how good you are why do you think people
like Andrew Tate are up there being like
Oh I have loads of guns and loads of
Range Rovers and loads of weap that
makes me a good man Andrew T has become
popular with young men because he is out
there STX he is out there for better or
worse and I think there are equal doses
of both with him for better or worse he
is a voice defending young men when
actually every other voice out there the
moment attack Andrew Tate is a voice
speaking to men with status anxiety
telling them Society tells you you're a
loser because you can't get a job and
you don't have any money buy a load of
guns abuse women get a Range Rover and
then you'll be worth something and
that's so dumb all right like that's not
how you need the participation medal
that's what some of need it you know get
inequality in society I think there'll
always be winners and losers and I think
it's the way we handle it to to to say
that actually we need a society that
doesn't have winners or losers is quite
it's not that we need a soet
the unfortunately I now win cuz I get to
stay on the show you three lose cuz
you're being removed from you'll invite
us back anyway you know against my
better judgment yes I will lovely to see
you
all